we're going to bring you some breaking
news out of southern pakistan at least
20 people have been killed in an
earthquake and hundreds more have been
injured it measured 5.7 and it happened
in the early hours of thursday while
people were sleeping the worst hit area
is reported to be the city of hanai in
balochistan province rescue efforts are
said to be more difficult because a lot
of the roads are bad and cell phone
coverage is poor kamal hara is joining
me now on the phone from islamabad what
more do we know about what's going on
there come on
what we do know is that this earthquake
happened in the early hours of the
morning according to local time
most people were in their homes
according to the deputy commissioner
most of the casualties include women and
children
20 confirmed dead 200
injured according to the latest figures
and as you mentioned
this is a remote region it is about 60
kilometers from the provincial capital
quetta
and because of the earthquake many of
the
roads leading to harnai have been
blocked by landslides or rock slides and
therefore that is hampering the rescue
effort
not to mention the fact that electricity
supply was cut off because of the
earthquake this was a shallow earthquake
15 kilometer depth and that's why there
was considerable damage it shook the
provincial capital quetta also forcing
people
out of their homes the rescue efforts
are still underway it is first night
so the rescue effort of course will
gather pace but we are told that the
more
seriously injured have been rushed to
hospitals in quetta
you said that this was a shallow quake
as we mentioned before it was 5.7 on on
the scale how common is this kind of
incidence
uh baluchistan is seismically active
this is also a confluence of several
tectonic plates
uh it has seen many major earthquakes a
few years ago we covered a major
earthquake in the avaron region
also a remote district so earthquakes is
nothing new in baluchistan
this particular area is not very heavily
populated so that would be one good sign
however most of the construction there
is mud houses made from rocks and mud
and so those structures do not stand a
chance against any heavy jewel as i also
mentioned the shallow earthquakes leave
more devastation
and because of the shock effect from the
the depth which is just 15 kilometers
however we have no reports of any major
uh damage in the provincial capital
this earthquake of course was felt over
a large area and we also heard that
small aftershocks have continued after
that 5.7
uh magnitude quake
well obviously we're still in the early
stages of getting the details of this
and we're going to be coming back to you
as we find out more in the next few
hours but kamal haider from islamabad
for now thank you very much indeed